and what we're trying to do in this
podcast is to offer some solutions to
how to have some preemptive measures
and some damage control how to deal with
these issues how to
talk about sexual education what age we
talked about that
in the previous podcast as well when can
we address these issues how should we
address these issues with their kids
what does it mean to get ready for
marriage and when is there the right
time and so on we talked about readiness
and so on so it goes to now to the issue
okay like how how do you
what is permissible so let's say you are
now
a young man or a woman right you're
ready to get married you want to get
married somehow convince your parents or
whatever and you're ready to do it so
you find someone who likes or how do you
find someone it's quite difficult
actually
um muslims cannot just walk on the
street and be like hey girl what's up
you know and start
talking and just try to um engage and
flirt or whatnot right it's it's believe
it or not
people are having a hard time finding
[Music]
spouses
and that's the kind of the fundamental
the the basis of it right in that
connection
you have the actual you know emotional
connection with your beliefs and
everything being in line
you have the sexual connection which is
intimacy being in line both are
necessary you need them
um so focus on that and just think about
how many things you didn't know
that we just talked about now right and
i'll think about how much more there is
that you probably don't know because you
grew up in a society where they don't
talk about these things and they're
shunned
they shouldn't be shunned because if
they're shuns then you won't have good
intimacy then your marriage breaks apart
then your family breaks apart and if all
the families in community break apart
it's not good
it starts here and with that being said
may i bless you all and grant us
good spouses and children who will be
the coolness of our eyes and allow us to
be leaders for the righteous people
welcome back to the realist podcast in
the dunya the three muslims podcast
we're your hosts rami fayad and angel
we're back with our brother gabriel as
romani salamu alaikum
allah
so last time by the way if you haven't
watched the first two episodes go watch
them first
it is important highly important that
you watch them in order
so go back and make sure you check those
out insha'allah but when you finish
episode two this being episode three
five finish off with the question that
we're going to start today's episode off
what can we do with the potential spouse
what's permissible
and what's not pre nika
okay alhamdulillah
to understand the importance of of this
podcast so we're talking about intimacy
and we're going to build towards that
and it's going to get more and more
controversial i guess because
it is very taboo as we spoke in the
first episode
um the muslim community is quite um
i say not ready not willing to talk
about these things even though they're
so
important and they're all over us all
around us
um the world is a village it's not
anymore the east versus the west or you
can be safe in some country somewhere
with the mass media social media
everyone's exposed to these things
and what we're trying to do in this
podcast is to offer some solutions to
how to have some preemptive measures
and some damage control how to deal with
these issues how to
talk about sexual education what age we
talked about that
in the previous podcast as well when can
we address these issues how should we
address these issues with our kids
what does it mean to get ready for
marriage and when is there the right
time and so on we talked about readiness
and so on so it goes to now to the issue
okay like how how do you
what is permissible so let's say you are
now
a young man or a woman right you're
ready to get married you want to get
married somehow convince your parents or
whatever and you're ready to do it so
you find someone you like or how do you
find someone it's quite difficult
actually
muslims cannot just walk on the street
and be like hey girl what's up you know
and start
talking and just try to um engage and
flirt or whatnot right it's it's believe
it or not
people are having a hard time finding
spouses
people are having a hard time the
muslims themselves from different
like i was talking to one of my clients
and the criteria that he's he's got a
he's got a bit
he's very it's very narrow so he has to
be uh um
a person from the subcontinent
and it has to be from a doctor
background
so obviously that's very very narrow
pool right
so gonna be very difficult i told him
right so i we tried to work with his
parents to kind of
widen the spectrum a little bit but man
it was difficult
right so i think what i want to tell the
brothers and sisters and
just to raise awareness their parents
that i think you need to lax
the the spectrum a bit i'm not saying
lacks the
way or ecologists do whatever no what
i'm trying to say is that just
widen the spectrum a little bit when it
comes to options when it comes to races
when it comes to
ethnicities when it comes to backgrounds
and so on
just allow for a few other
possibilities not just one or two
options because
it's very difficult so then again you're
faced with you know being 29 30
35 and not being able to get married so
it's very difficult to find
someone to get married the what what are
options so you have the online things
right now
whatever different platforms that they
have
and subhanallah these guys are making a
lot of money um it is a
very sought after service to
hook people online and problem the
problem is that some of these
applications
and websites have become like dating
websites where
you know even zinn has been reported
where people just hook up
and whatnot and you know commit commit
indecencies and and all these things
right so
maybe the intention to get these
services was good to start with
because obviously in such a huge ummah
right you got 2 billion plus
it's very difficult for people to to
connect not
easy whatsoever okay
so the question becomes what is
permissible what is impermissible so the
scholars have been talking about this
because the means and the the avenues of
getting to
know a potential spouse have changed so
back in the days
what would happen is usually
traditionally that a family would
recommend someone or they would know
someone
the mother would go and see the daughter
of another friend and
you know they'll be friends together
families
and they would basically um propose
and then the if the boy and the girl
would see each other for a bit
and then they would get married of
course you didn't have some of the
fitting or the problems that we have
today with social
media pornography and all that so in
general a lot of the marriages
were moving forward people didn't know
anything we're going to get to this when
it comes to intimacy right
they didn't have experiences
other than just the normal desire and
the fitra
so humans are programmed to be intimate
allah subs
and has created us in such a way that
when a man and woman get together it
just
it just goes you know and if you have
not had any corruption of your fitrah
and any previous experiences then
naturally that's the only thing you know
so it'll be a great experience in
general subhanallah right
that is a beautiful thing actually but
fast forward to the 21st century and the
issues that we're faced with today
that's what we always say in islam
there's what we should do and then
there's the reality of what has happened
right so allah deals with both allah
tells us
how we should behave what should we do
and then what should we do in case we
fail to do those things right
how to make tawba how to amend and how
to get back to
on track but the issue is that once
you've made a mistake obviously you
cannot
forget it so you're already somehow
stained
but obviously 21st century i know you
don't have that
you know if i was a father back in the
days you go to mosque see a nice young
man
he's coming for fajr every day
masha'allah and you go and say amen
i have a daughter you know would you
like to marry her you know what i mean
and because i see you like a good man
mashallah coming for fajr
strong guy you know what you're known in
the community
right this this is how it would work
but now there's just so much happening
there's just so many people
how do you get to know someone okay
let's say you don't have a family
like a muslim family like myself for
example i did not
have a muslim family when i became
muslim
i was just like what 19 years old
and i was in university and i wanted to
get married the first thing i wanted to
do is get married
and subhanallah i tried
and talked to people and i was refused
left and right why because i
i'm a new muslim so how does a new
muslim find a spouse
how does a new muslim find someone to
get married to
for a girl a bit easier because she's a
new muslim
masha allah you know they don't have to
be looking they're looked after usually
but for a guy it's quite difficult to
find a woman how does he approach
someone how does he go
to a family and say i'm a new muslim can
i marry your daughter
most families will say no because
they're worried
right because the marriage is also like
kind of you know today anyway and with
the
traditional cultures of islam that it's
a union between two families and
there's expectations there to have
in-laws and families and visit each
other and whatnot
so like someone like myself angel what
do we do what do we go to you know what
i mean like who's going to represent
us right people have to understand this
and
you know some of the scholars have
looked at this and have said okay maybe
the imam with the mosque can arrange or
this and that in the end bottom line is
that it's not that simple
so how do we do who do we marry how do
we go about it
it's not a very straightforward answer
right bottom line is that we have to
understand the general
rules of islam that we shouldn't step
outside of
and try our best to stick with okay and
that is obviously not to do anything
haram
not to commit any sins not to
uh you know to to do anything that would
compromise our ethics and morals
okay these are the general terms that
can be applied to be it
online platforms or you know
talking to someone and this and this so
bottom line is is uh you know it's it's
not a black and white it's not a
you know clear-cut answer like that we
need to look at
what is available out there so what is
available i said online okay can you go
online and look for a spouse yes you can
it's permissible
uh you what do you have you go through
profiles right
um okay but then it needs to the next
thing then you get to contact that
person
um what is the the vetting procedure
um is there some kind of filter or
someone who's
supervising that can you send some
questions to that person and they can
send you questions yes you can
yes you should you should make sure that
you have some understanding of who that
person is
before you get married can you be alone
with them and have chats and discussions
and all that
this is where it gets a bit tricky right
because
people do that anyway okay again people
need to understand
that bottom line is people are going to
do things
does it make it permissible no not
necessarily
but how do you deal with that people do
talk people will communicate
people will have discussions all right
people will have these kind of
interactions
it's so easy today and even if you're
not looking for marriage
one way or the other you're gonna have
to communicate to a female in work or
this or that exchange emails whatsapps
and so on and i think it's in almost
every dynamic
i'm as a school principal i have to
interact with
female teachers and you know messages
they send me messages
uh groups this that it will happen i'm
not going to be hypocrite you know but
there has to be certain
guidelines and how you're going to go
about it you know what i mean
you find sometimes you go to a scholarly
lecture there'll be women who are line
up to ask the shaykh
question you know what i mean so they
will ask they'll talk they'll send a
message they'll send the
note they will this and that it happens
the prophet entertained
discussions with women they asked him
questions
they came to him as i said even the
previous you know and sometimes asking
questions about intimacy about
certain things a man also
so there's a dynamics of discussion and
conversation between the opposite gender
that has to be
is going to be there but there has to be
some clear
you know ethics and morals and how we go
about it because
it can lead no doubt about it to
problems and to issues and when people
talk and talk and talk and then they
lose respect for each other
then obviously that's going to cause
problems
in the future so it's it's hard for me
to say
this or that because there are also some
difference of opinion as to what is
allowed and what is not allowed
uh different scholars will say different
things
but bottom line is the general framework
is
to be careful to have respect to have
um you know uh some form of protection
or if there's there can be a way um for
example right now i introduced one
brother to a family for marriage
just recently a couple days ago so the
way we went about it
is that the family created a group a
whatsapp group and
he was added to it and there's just the
girl and the guy and
a third person to just kind of overlook
that you know
and they are asking each other questions
and communicating but there's just
someone else there who
might see some of these discussions you
know what i mean so that's how they
they decided to go about and i think
it's it's a it's a decent way because
um someone from her family is is there
to just kind of overlook things
right now what about two new muslims
a girl and a boy who don't have anyone
right they
they and they do come and say look we've
been talking for a long time
and we're talking uh and her father
knows that i'm talking to her
or her mother knows i'm talking to her
or someone knows that i'm talking to her
yeah i understand i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna say
that this is the best case scenario it's
okay but these things happen so when i'm
talking about
in these podcasts i'm talking about the
reality of what happens
i'm not going to say permissible and
permissible this and that
because there's a huge discussion
however what we know very clear what's
impermissible in islam
is for two people to be alone together
because then it can escalate
for two people to be what's called halwa
or to be you know in this
private setting which can be you know in
whatsapp it can be
through you know chatting through video
whatever it is
these things can lead to problems and
subhanallah you you're a human being
you're gonna slip
like we know the story of barcis of the
monk right we're mentioning it
he was much better than all of us right
and he slipped into it right so
the story that the process em told us
about that story was to show that even a
very religious person
can easily slip right so islam has put
some guideline and some
has demarcated some you know territory
for us to be careful not to step out of
that
bottom line again does it happen do
people
really respect these rules and norms no
can you just say okay a lot of people
are are saying look we cannot
there's no way so i think the
communities have to come up
with new modalities of people to get to
know each other
to um to see each other
i think it is a crisis that we're facing
in today
this is a big crisis that people are
delaying marriage
not only because of excuses of work and
not having money it's also genuinely
because they cannot find someone
they cannot find someone to get married
too
so people will you know other options
are obviously in university you see a
sister and you like her and you approach
someone or you talk to someone do you
know her
talk to your parents okay they might
reject you they might accept you i don't
know you see someone at the mosque you
talk to the imam
approach the family these are some of
the options that can
happen in sha allah and
i definitely believe though that to find
a way
that is halal to be able to vet each
other vetting
each other is very important don't just
go into the marriage without having no
clue who this person is
and that's what the prophet sam said
make sure for example to want a sahabi
said make sure you see her
so can you see the woman yes you should
be able to see him some say even that
you should
be able to see her in her house for
example you can ask to see her without
hijab
some say no there's a discussion and
debate on that but
some say yes if you ask for permission
her family is okay with it that you can
maybe go into the house
with her family and then you know she
just wears like her house clothes or
whatever and comes and you can see her
okay um
some sahabah were like hiding you know
the process sallam and he told the
process that i'm like he was hiding and
looking her but
nia was not bad to like check her out or
like sexual or something
it's just to see if he likes her there's
chemistry chemistry is very important i
think a lot of muslims make the mistake
of just marrying without having
no desire or chemistry for the other
person
and then they think oh it will come it
will come
you know when the process
he mentions in his um
he says that the
the uncle the prophet of some said
muhammad
is like the stallion that cannot be
controlled that's how you describe them
okay like the stallion that cannot be
ringed okay the words
and he desires khadija and khadija
desires him
you know it was like a like a speech you
know
like subhanallah when i don't know when
i when i hear those words it's like
there's
it's not like oh you know we just get
married and let's see what happens like
khadijah proposed to the prophet saw
khadijah was infatuated i hope i'm using
the correct word and no one's gonna you
know have my neck for this
but she liked the prophet saw sallam and
she liked what he represented she saw
him
what what he did for her he was
a man who could get things done you
understand
that's why when he went with the caravan
and he did the business
okay he'd get things done so she was
impressed by that and she got a lot of
proposals she was very wealthy woman
many men wanted her
she wanted him why because he was a real
guy
and that's what i love the description
the stallion that cannot be
ringed because people might think the
process
was just like you know just like soft
you know and he was soft when he had to
be soft
the prophet sam was no just you know
soft person like he was
he was he was strong when he had to be
strong he was very
strong and when they called for him to
be softer
then he was soft so
i think a lot of people make a mistake
in marrying without
knowing each other without seeing each
other without vetting and i think the
community
need to provide avenues halal avenues
for
brothers and sisters to vet each other
to ask each other questions scenarios
to discuss things to feel to have some
proximity to an extent
in public setting in a way where you
know someone's aware
where they can feel each other because
you're going to live with this person
next
the whole your whole life don't expect
these things are just going to happen
they're just going to change a lot of
people
say that after marriage things changed
totally 180
degrees you know and they didn't know
there wasn't they weren't expecting that
they had a certain image of how marriage
is going to be
when they get married and then they say
i feel like i married a different person
like i didn't know who he is
and i'm like yeah but did you like ask
him some questions but no but i believe
like our elders and our family
they thought that is right and i just
wanted to yeah of course you should be
nice to your family and obey them and
they want only good for you but the
prophesym said very clearly
that you have to seek the permission of
the person
you have to seek the permission of the
woman
and the permission of the virgin is her
silence
okay so even the virgin woman will be
asked you know do you like this guy you
want to marry him not like okay guys we
got him married
with all due respect to some of the
cultures you know for the arranged
marriages
it's your it it's not necessarily people
say yeah but you know our marriage
worked
a lot of marriages before because of the
cultural pressures were working but
today you live in a society where
individualism is encouraged there's so
many resources
education is you know exploded
everyone's doing things everyone's
so people are very independent now
independence is a culture
where that's where people are just
walking their own ways now it's so easy
to divorce today
so that's why the divorce rates are so
high back in the days it was not so easy
so people stuck together even though
they might have suffered
but they're just doing it like i know
many couples
that i've dealt with uh from the other
that generation who haven't slept
together for 20 years
they're just together for uh for the
children just for the appearances
20 25 years they have not touched each
other
they just live like strangers in the
house together
so yes it looks like they're together
but they're not together
right just four stuff and they suffer
and men have broken down and cried and
men have
and women have broken down and cried
because
keeping up appearances is not easy and
that's again our problem as an ummah
we are fair working very hard to keep up
appearances
yet when someone comes and talk real
talk we just shut them down
and we don't like it it's uncomfortable
because it's true and it
forces us to move out of our comfort
levels
and to face reality and it hurts it it's
it's not feeling well because we know
it's real
we know that this is what this is not we
cannot we cannot
hide anymore it's the 21st century
information
flows faster than water you know what i
mean you cannot run away from it
but we need to solve these problems so
we need to find
systems where brothers and sisters can
meet talk vet in a halal environment
and not be forced to marry if they don't
like it and not be rushed
till they understand each other and yes
in a way to feel that there's some
some um attraction
a lot of men make these mistakes and
women there's no attraction for that
person and trust me you will know what
attraction is man
when you're attracted to someone you'd
be like am i really attracted to this
person
i don't know come on man you will know
whether you're attracted to someone
that's like it's just instinct and same
for the girl
the woman also you know they don't
verbalize that as much but they do
girls like a handsome guy they like
you know they have a certain idea of
what a man should be
and it's okay it's their right isn't it
it's their right that's why
khadijah had a certain idea of what she
wanted from a man that's why she refused
all the other guys
from quraish who came with money and
this and that
and she didn't want it because she had a
certain
type that she wanted and she got it
and it was the prophet salallahu
right but when we force it and we push
it and
the girl makes the mistake saying yeah i
think
i'm sure that after nikah i will fall in
love with him or i'm not saying that all
of a sudden you fall in love with him
before marriage but you'll feel
something
and if you're not true to your feelings
you might have problems
i'm not saying the feelings don't
develop later on yes in some cases they
will
but again going based on my experience
dealing with these
counseling couples a lot of people
go down even more and they regret
marrying and then they
divorce or have problems and whatnot the
same for the guys the guys think that
a lot of guys come to the dean and they
say you know
okay i'm gonna marry a religious girl
and she's so religious
and they don't know but she's a bad wife
she's bad wife material and she's
religious masha'allah she's praying the
whole night but she's not sleeping with
you
and the guy's suffering so guys you know
uh
i don't addicted to porn because his
wife is praying the whole night and
fasting every day you know
and she's very religious masha'allah but
actually she's not
because she did not understand what
islam really is in priority because
it is farred for her to make sure her
husband is
happy with her while it is sunnah for
her to pray qiyam and leyland fast
okay and this is very clear so it means
she did not understand islam properly so
her religion is not good
actually her religion even though she's
doing appearing to be very religious but
actually
her understanding is is not correct
right but he jumped he prematurely
selected her because he was fooled by
the image
and he did not ask her the correct
questions because in the end the image
has to meet what's inside
if the two have they're not congruent
then you're having a problem
so you might marry a woman who's like a
scholar masha'allah but she's
not a good wife and
allah knows best if that her prayers and
her things will be accepted while her
husband
is suffering you know what i mean
uh again priorities islam is a dean of
priorities
it's very important to have priorities
and to understand
what comes in where is praying bad no
it's very good
it's praying you're saying i'm praying
qiyam i'm praying to allah
yes you are very good masha'allah but
i'm not happy with you
you understand and allah doesn't ask you
to pray
extra more than the five daily prayers
but he asks you
to give me some attention
right so again there's a proper
flaw in the vetting procedure
same with the girl oh you know he's a
nice guy everyone thinks he's a nice guy
everyone likes him i didn't really feel
for him
but you know i just went with it and
then she's like
you know she's rejecting intimacy and
then you
ask her why are you it's like i'm i'm
disgusted by him i feel like puking
every time i look at him i'm like but
didn't you see him before he got married
yeah but i thought that maybe i don't
know if allah will make it easy for me
okay you thought allah will make it easy
for you may allah make it easy for you
but
it still doesn't change the way you feel
about him isn't it like i've
you know some clients say i can't even
like touch
my husband or i can't even look at him
like
i can't so what do you do in that case
how do you teach the muslim um that you
have to have some preemptive measures
before you get mad don't just jump in
don't just you know do it just like that
no the sahabas subhanallah they married
they divorced
the sahabas vetted they looked they
tried they you know it was
marriage was not so taboo as it is it
was not so overrated as
it is today honestly i challenge anyone
to look into the life of the sahaba
i challenge everyone to see how they
looked at marriage
subhan allah the wife of
jaffa radhiallahu
i mean she married jaffar okay she
married
um after jaffar
i think you know abu bakr and ali
right i mean subhanallah you know you
see
marrying three sahabas right
she could have been like no i've made
the khalas i'm done you know no
subhanallah the way they looked at
marriage is totally different
the way the prophet saws married safiyah
uh you know his wives
i don't know where are we like why do we
not take that as a standard why don't we
look into the seer of the prophet
extract solutions for our life why are
we allowing our cultures and our
own minds and understanding to take
precedence
over the quran and sunnah people keep
saying quran
but when you put it to be in pragmatic
quran is an application
then where is the quran sunnah right
where is the quran sunnah it's culture
it's this is that there's racism
discrimination amongst the communities
oh he's like this oh he's
he's white he's black no i don't want
black no i don't want why why is somali
he is this he's a convert i know he has
to be like this
it has to be like that it's like man you
know we're having so
many problems where is islam here
why are we having different mosques with
different ethnicities
where is the the brotherhood the
universal brotherhood that we
we call upon we're racist we're dis we
discriminate
so much especially when it comes to
marriage and that is why it makes it
very difficult for
certain people to get married this makes
huge problem
for a lot of people to get married you
know
uh there's a certain you know a
tire of people only who's gonna get more
chances to get married
because of the way we set up our
cultures and our
our societies so these are some of the
challenges we're faced with
and i think the the scholars need to
talk more about it we need to
re-examine the fake of dealings
of marriage of pre-marriage um
have some pre-marriage courses we're
talking about intimacy
yeah you guys have no clue what they're
doing and the women don't know what to
expect
and that's where the the first night is
one of the most
traumatic nights for many women and men
because we're not addressing these
issues we are not vetting each other
properly we're not preparing for
marriage because we delay it and we
delay talking about it energy
educate about it it's so taboo it's so
you know the non-muslims are
you know tasting the cake before they
buy it they go here left
right they do this they do that they
date
all this right so even so they're still
failing and forget about it marriage
right now is not even on their list
right
it's so much easier to just mess about
so you're competing with that you know
what i mean you're competing with that
and you're putting all these extra
blocks on the way and then again we're
wondering why
we're delaying marriage why marriages
are failing
because we are not making it easier
we're not offering solutions
so scholars need to talk about like we
cannot only
us solve this issue other than raise
awareness we hope that
scholars see this uh this podcast and
they say okay let's get together
have a conference where we discuss like
right now in malaysia
on the fourth there's a brother that i
know and he's
having i'll tell you how he does it and
i you know i don't mind advertising
i mean it's gonna be probably by this
time it gets podcasted but
um i think it's called soul seekers
and basically what he does is he invites
everyone to one hotel okay
and they pay a fee and then they all go
to hotel
with you know men women
daughters fathers wallies families right
and then he has a certain ticketing
system and then there's
a sort of a filter so you kind of like
you know there's some matching that
happens and then in the end basically
there's
open tables in public where brothers and
sisters can sit
face to face and then they basically
like that's like the last stage of the
conference
where they can discuss and ask each
other you know questions and the wallies
can be their
family or anyone represented and then
they basically if that is
okay then they take it to the next level
and the i think they facilitate
for another meeting and then some more
discussions and then if it
it's good to go then they agree and they
they they tie the knot
you know you ever heard of a speed
dating
what is it called speed dating speed
dating now
that's what it sounds like yeah that's
what it sounds like maybe that's where
they took it from
i was about to say where the sign ups at
uh so yeah so i mean that's an option i
mean i'm not sure
um because it is open it is quite
controlled from what i looked at
i'll tell you what it what it's called
because i've advertised for it
but it's something that that can be an
okay it's called
by the way this is going up towards the
end of ramadan so i think it's enough
time
yeah but no i think this is happening on
the third of april oh it's already like
past i think oh then we're going
yeah so yeah so it's it's masha'allah i
mean it's it's a good uh
it's a good will you marry me it cause
33 matching success rate events for
singles and divorcees family members
welcome
complete privacy and confidentiality and
it's in
kuala lumpur mid valley city
hotel whatever so it's a way to
facilitate you know some of these
meetings where you can do it in public
and whatnot
i mean that's that's something i i wish
i'd have more solutions
to to give you you know what i mean but
it's it's a very sensitive topic because
again the the the the line between halal
and haram can be very fine
you know what i mean and very easy to
step over
let me let me ask one question if that
was all for that topic
give some advice to brothers that are in
a
haram relationship or have you know
just it's not a halal it's not a cat
it's not a marriage and
they weren't religious all right they
weren't
fully following islam they were kind of
you know they knew what
that what they're doing is wrong but
they weren't really you know ten toes
down about islam
they recently got more into islam and
now it's kind of like a contradiction
because they realize that
i follow islam now which tells me i
shouldn't do this and i i want to
you know i stopped all sins i want to
stop this too
but uh you know i still don't want to
leave the person or maybe they're just
like
you know it's been years they're
invested what do these people do
yeah i mean they just have to man up and
just
just tie the knot you know i mean just
make it serious if you're serious about
that person you really like them
just make it halal you know the
difference between halal is very simple
you know
it's your witnesses your mahar
just just just do it right repent
and just make it clean even with that
person
even if the person is not a muslim you
know as a christian or whatever al-kitab
you can still marry them and you know
pray to allah that allah will make it
easy
or you decide to to take to take
take a walk man and just leave it you
know for allah right
and that is something that is not easy i
understand that i understand that people
have spent a lot of time together and
they got used to each other they love
each other
but if you really love that person that
make it get
allah's blessing in it you know what i
mean it's not difficult to make nikah
it's very simple make the nikah you know
i make the nikah is it can be happening
in minutes you know what i mean why earn
the anger of allah
while you can earn his pleasure so
imagine all that time you're spending
with that woman
is a sin and all you have to do is
make a nikah so all the time you will
spend with her will be an ajar and a
blessing
it's just as simple you just totally
flip everything
you know by just making the nika so make
the nikaf you really love her you really
care about her
then care about her you know her dean
and her life and her
and yours as well and just do it right
just making
you know don't don't make it difficult
don't think about this huge marriage
bro just hit up the imam go to the
masjid
pick two brothers to make you know to be
your witnesses
i don't know who she is she has a wally
or not if you know
if she's a muslim what
make the nikah you know and get the imam
involved to be the wali if it is
and just make danika just do it right
rami how quick can the cows be
how quick can nikahas be very quick
very quick five minutes three minutes
five minutes bismillah
yeah just read like some uh
just read like like what you hear the
beginning of like the khutbah
a little bit in arabic talk about a few
verses in the quran
[Music]
all right man so romney you're going to
do money for me i'm gonna have gabriel
and fire that's my two witnesses that's
it that it's as simple as that bro
i i know people would cringe over this
but honestly it is basically as simple
as that like the process that made nikah
coming back from war
the apostles said yeah i mean you know
people will be like surprised you know
but that's the reality you know again
i don't know what's wrong with our
community sometimes but i think
we just need to go back to these simple
you know kisses keep it sweet and sunnah
you know keep it sweet and simple and
just uh just take it up and just
because again the harder we make it the
more haram
because haram is very easy you know it's
very simple
right it's very simple you see
this whole id ideal ideological
way that marriage has been set up and
that's not marriage bro that's that's a
wedding
that's that's you know you gotta spend
this much month's paycheck on a ring or
a ring
and then you gotta just have random
people your wedding you don't even
bought
you gotta propose you gotta do some
elaborate thing that's what that's what
you see
watching fairy tale netflix disney you
know
we're talking about marriage we're not
talking about weddings
yes our lima you know this sunnah to
have a nice ceremony to celebrate but
to make it halal i would put that over
cultural norms societal norms
anything like that i guess that's that's
what it is right it's about what what's
been
infiltrated from the media and there's
nothing if you
look if you can have a big party or you
have the ability palace man
you know go ahead but do your nikah
first become halal
then if you guys want to do something
later on or you want to plan for a party
or whatever
it's all good if you got the finances if
not
if you want to start your life with a
loan and a debt
then that's not the right person for you
man if she's gonna be willing to push
you through that stuff
okay to start your life with a big debt
to pay i don't know what much money and
this and that to have this big
party that you're gonna be dancing in
front of strange men and whatnot
i i think you should reconsider that you
know what i mean
but if you guys want to have some kind
of thing you know a reception
what him after and you know you you can
it's like chump change for you and no
issues this will not go ahead
but if it's going to cause any strain
and any problem on you and then you know
you're going to start your life in the
minus
is that what you want
tuition fees and all that now
i said you got me thinking about like
university tuition fees and all of that
starting off negative it's tough man
it's tough right i mean that's that's
what it is most people will be working
up to their
you know 30s 40s paying off student
loans
paying off debts because you know
the what do you call the the culture
conditions you to
make sure you tick all these boxes do i
have this do i have that
tick tick tick tick tick
but you know a real man
he is not he's not a slave to anyone
other than allah that's one the
conditions of being real men
if you have if you owe someone something
then you are basically indebted to them
and it is a big issue in islam
it is a big issue because if you died
that way
then there's a problem right so
you have that in the back of your mind
if anything changes that dynamics of
your lifestyle look with covet 19
how many people suffered because
they were in a fake lifestyle
they had the car they had the house when
you look at them you're like wow
masha'allah
what a cute family what a successful
person as soon as they lost their job or
their finances tilted
boom everything was gone because it was
just
you know smoke it was nothing real right
so be careful how you position yourself
you know what i mean you might
think you own things but actually they
own you
so a real man does not allow himself to
be even look
like as one brother said you know he
says islamic
banking if you cannot afford it don't
buy
you know what i mean basically that's
what i said you know because everyone
wants to take a loan everyone's saying
oh
halal money islam loan this and that
okay but what you're going to do you're
going to be in minus
for the rest of your life he's going to
hur i don't know
my friend i gave me shahada we entered
university at the same time
he um he exited university two years
later than me
but with no debt zero debts
i exited university with i think it was
twenty eight thousand dollars there
okay because i had some scholarships and
i was working and whatnot so i think i
had about 28 000
when i graduated but at that time i
think
i was just two three years into islam
and i just made my move to the khaleej
it was eight months bro i was eating
noodles and you know my treat was like a
mcdonald's burger you know because it
was like halal right
so i'll eat some big mac here and there
noodles sausages
cereal and i think i paid the debt in
like eight months
you know what i mean it was like
literally tighten the belt and since
then i did not owe anyone anything man
like i taken a few things here and there
a few loans here and then i just
readjusted
and alhamdulillah you know it was just
the biggest
blessing in the life was to like just to
go to sleep
knowing that you don't own you don't owe
anyone anything
and you graduated you graduated with 28
000 cad
that's actually pretty low for yeah
because i had some scholarships and i
was working as well at the same time
because by the time i realized that it
was haram and whatnot so when i became
muslim
i tried to make a few adjustments but i
think what i was trying to make the
point was that my friend the guy who
gave me shahada kamal
you graduated two years later but not
that
zero that because he applied the
principle he told me
before we entered university at that
time i was not muslim yet
and i was like he was just already
planning and i was like bro just do it
easy man just take a loan it's so simple
and he's like nope
it's haram and this is going to come to
hunt me and i was like then i understood
you know i understood that's right
yeah respects yes a lot of times we see
something
and we're like oh i like that
and then somehow we justify
a necessity for we're like oh i need
that what it is that i'm doing but it's
like
well maybe right now you need it but you
can't afford it and you got to wait
a little bit longer and just because you
didn't wait now
it's going to take like six to eight
months to finish paying it off
no doubt no doubt this was a good
episode
islam is easy islam is simple it's not
supposed to be complicated
yeah yeah
oftentimes yo we're the only ones that
complicated ourselves for our life
you know that's true yeah that's true i
agree
yeah sharia is so beautiful sharia is
you know no interest no
none of this is insane stuff so i mean
that's the objective right that you're
supposed to be a servant and a slave
only to allah
right well if you look at the the
modern system and subhanallah the
non-muslims have figured it out you know
and that's why you find that again the
ones that are leading the game
is them because they realized early
enough they you know they
readjusted their working habits they
unplugged from the system they took leap
of faith they risked
without risking you'll never ever be
able to make if you just play it safe
and this is not just you know me talking
about like i don't know some
[Music]
the monk who sold this ferrari something
some book like that
i'm talking about when you look at the
life of the brussels salem
the risk was calculated but i mean he
risked a lot
and they they they took a lot you know i
mean just the battle of
better you know what a risk you know and
so many things leaving
at the battle of uh what a risk of
course they always put their trust in
allah and he was a prophet
but we see that
life was was a risk you know the risk to
live
mecca the comfort to go to medina to a
new land
everything you know the risk that it
takes to go to taif
you know to to receive what you receive
from there
there was always something if you don't
risk if you're just going to be
comfortable and just
wait for your paycheck and that's what
they condition you to do
and sometimes you get punished from
trying to to unplug from the system
right so it's it's comfortable to be
where you are in the familiar it's
uncomfortable and that's where the
growth is is in the uncomfortable zone
and again just look around what people
have done
but people still they there's that voice
in their mind that tells them
you can't do it and then there's their
families who add to that and say how
dare you even try you're gonna put us in
trouble
you're gonna you know get us away from
this comfortable zone that we're used to
so there's so many voices around you
telling you you're going to fail even
before you start
and if you listen to these voices you
will fail you will
fail and you're going to hesitate a lot
and the greatest another greatest
nemesis and you know for a real man is
hesitation hesitating is as destructive
as your
is your kryptonite you hesitate as a man
it is weakness it paramounts to weakness
and the more you hesitate in life and
the more you stumble and you trip on the
you know
in your path because you don't like to
be uncomfortable
the more you are going to lose and
you're going to reach a point in your
life you're going to regret it
and you're going to ask yourself what if
i didn't what if i took the chances
and you're going to regret that you will
regret it for sure
and sorry honey to to say even to the
brothers we're talking about intimacy
and marriage a lot of times is the
the wife that tells you you know just
just stick to what you have just don't
do this
come on you're going to put us in
difficulties you know this
and the guy you know just stays
and just submits and a lot of people
will tell you can do it
and it's up to you you you can prove
them right
by just or you can prove them wrong and
it's up to you what you're gonna do so
but i don't know the system that we have
today designed
um post-world war
the in nine to five the rat race
you know in the morning when i look in
the morning the traffic everyone jumping
on the highway
everyone eating while driving everyone's
stressed
you know coming home the same thing
reaching home late
you know no no doubt we're gonna have
problems in our in our
society in our communities this is not
this is not the way to live we didn't
live like this for
thousands of years
for thousands of years we did not
live like this we lived based on what we
needed
we traded we did business
we had trade we had all kinds of stuff
and we were doing good and now for the
past
50 to 70 years there's a system
after the industrial revolution after
all these things where
you know it's almost like you know i
cannot unplug i cannot
do something and not everyone will i'm
not saying most people will not do it
that's the whole thing it's just a
it's just a natural you know way the
ones who will who will wake up
and the ones who won't will not not all
people believe
not all sahaba stayed on islam not all
uh people you know i mean we cannot call
them sahaba because obviously one of the
reasons that your sahaba is to
die as a muslim and believing in the
process but
basically not all the people follow the
process not all the people
went that way not all the people are
going to
uh become entrepreneurs not all the
people are going to do podcasts and
and make a living out of it even you
know what i mean not all the people are
going to
take these risks you know to quit their
job or to
you know to to reinvent themselves or to
rebrand themselves or to do something
that
others have not or even that some have
done already and you're like you know
what i can do it as well if this person
did it i can do it
most people are going to be okay to just
move on
with when they call normal
life but i mean it's not really normal
you know
and that's why you know we cannot
i don't know islam as you said it's
simple you know that's why we're having
i mean imagine talking about marriage
right that's why i had also with some of
my clients i said
you know with the women that work okay i
said to the
to the sisters you're complaining about
you're not being intimate with your
husband
but he's coming home 8 p.m and you're
coming home at 9 00 p.m
you know of course you're not you what
do you mean you're gonna be intimate
that's the last thing you want to do
after a day of horrible interactions in
your office with some
bad boss who's screaming on your back
and this and that
and all that is affecting you all that
negative energy
and then you come home and couples are
saying like we have intimacy once every
two weeks
and we're having problems honestly bro
once every two weeks
like this is now an average amongst the
nine to five working muslim ummah who
um both both husband and wife are
working
once every two weeks on the weekend
maybe and it's because it's so
staged and it's so like programmed it it
loses you know
it's like not even you know there's no
spontaneous you know
no spontaneous no sparks no nothing
okay we're being intimate saturday night
that's like the night
you know what i mean and it is
two weeks you can't plan intimacy
you know what i mean isn't it it's like
that sucks it's like so horrible he's
like
okay let's make it's like imagine you
you book it in your agenda you know what
i mean it's like
it's like okay reminder uh 30 minutes
left to intimacy you know
like you get one of those screen you
know reminds like what
that's horrible bro oh my god you spent
the entire week just looking at that
calendar like i can't wait till saturday
comes around she's like oh i'm working
overtime exactly or like your mom
calls you or something like that my boss
needs you for an overnight
uh extra credit my parents are coming
over
you know like oh man like
yeah y'all heard that stat the
most the time where most people have a
heart attack like the highest percentage
of heart attacks
monday monday morning 7am yep
monday morning yeah going back to work
man
but guys and girls a wonderful way to
sum up all the points
that brother gabriel al-rahmani just
made is if you take a risk
for allah you will get risk from allah
allah is meaning sustenance for anyone
that doesn't know what that is
sustenance money
just security
bless the three of you immensely and all
those who are watching make sure to keep
up with the series in sha allah when we
release episode four and again for some
reason you watch episode three without
watching the first two
go watch those two insha allah like
comment subscribe check out
brother gabriel el romani insha allah on
youtube
and instagram and what are your other
platforms
twitter yeah no not so much man ig tv
and youtube man that's
a lot of growth i've seen you didn't you
say you gotta only fans
[Laughter]
well we i mean uh we there there is a
problem in the muslim community with
that
after post kobe yeah
there's a lot of complaints yeah i mean
i i know people again with cringe but
there's been a lot of complaints of that
yeah well what are they they have the
jobs like on there and then they just
take the job off
could literally consist of nothing but
that
y'all could not even have sex and she
would literally
submit to you in every single way even
after the fact
and i i speak that from experience
but um for a lot of purposes if you do
that with your wife you will see
crazy things and if you're a woman
watching this
throw this over to your husband so he
can learn
the game if you're doing it properly and
stuff where she
climaxes even if it's just minor ones uh
multiple times
before you even actually start you know
having the real
intercourse and when you get to that
point you know you're doing it right
what i wanted to add about this whole
foreplay thing
is that a woman has
three stages of orgasm
have an orgasm stage one
all right stage two is orgasm from
penetration or orgasm from
your finger penetrating and hitting the
g-spot
that's like three four or five times
before
penetrating like you really don't have
to go fast at all
you could keep it super slow and just do
exactly what fire was uh
showing there and like you'll probably
have a bus another few times before it's
your time
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
you